all right what up guys welcome to the
just pearly things YouTube channel and
welcome to morning coffee thoughts I've
tried to film this like three times and
I keep not articulating myself the way I
want to
so I'm just gonna try to talk freely
this one but before I start don't forget
to subscribe to the channel ring that
notification Bell that way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos and
like the video so
this kind of goes with what I was about
to say
um what
I want to talk to you guys about is what
happens when you get bigger and I don't
know if I'm considered famous I get
recognized a decent amount especially
when I'm in the U.S like a lot more
um and I got 60 million views this month
which is more than Vlad TV but
I don't think I'm like
famous to the like I don't know I think
there's people more famous than me and I
think I kind of look like a
like I'm a normal looking white girl so
I don't think in a crowd I stand up that
much other than the fact that I'm really
tall
um I don't know you could you could say
I am or I'm not but
that's not the point the point is when
you get bigger
you kind of have to change the way you
talk a little bit and I really hate it
because I think what people like about
me and what comes across on camera is
I'm very authentic and I'm very open and
honest
and
the problem is when you get bigger and
there's you know I talk for 12 hours a
week and there's clip after clip after
clip of me talking or whatever
people tend to take things out of
context
and they you know when you talk for 12
hours straight they will find something
or anything that contradicts you or like
you know have I ever said things that
contradict each other probably
have I ever said anything that I wasn't
correct about probably yeah of course
yes yes
and if I say something wrong I'll
correct it in the future it's like duh
duh like um I used to say
the one clip of me I'll tell you that I
was I was off by five percent I said it
your chances of a happy marriage goes
down from 80 to 25 if you've had five or
more bodies it's actually 30 percent
and I think it was six or more bodies I
think I was off by one sorry ladies you
you get one more you get one more
and there's different studies that um
say different things that that one was
the I could can't think of the name off
the top of my head that one was like the
most extreme but there's ones where it
goes down by like less but the point is
the percentage still goes down
um another example of something that
someone took out of context was
[Music]
I said I never lived with a guy before
and
that's kind of true but it's also not
true and I'll I'll explain so my
ex-boyfriend
um when we first started dating he
needed a place to stay like he was
staying in um hotels because he did it
was it's a long story but he didn't have
his documents like he lost them and we
were helping him get his ID so my
parents put him on our lease at my
parents house
um temporarily while he got a new place
so he stayed with my parents for like a
month and me and we had separate rooms
but when I think of like living with a
guy I think of like
y'all get an apartment together you know
you you know what I mean like I think
like
and so they're like you didn't live you
move and then they're like you moved in
with a guy right away and like you say
to vet guys and I was just like
well we both were YouTubers so we spent
a lot of time together early on
um
you know maybe
maybe I shouldn't have did that that
soon but it was more just like he needed
help you know it was like just trying to
be nice anyways and then they're like
well you moved in with him right away
and I'm like okay I never lived lived
lived with him it was just like anyways
a temporary thing but then then okay I
tell these stories and the problem is
the bigger you get people go and find
the people in the stories
like I told a story of a girl from
college who cheated on her boyfriend
okay
now look guys
what I learned with cheating
is I have been the tattletale before I
have been the tattletail for both the
men and the women what I've learned is
it doesn't matter people are gonna stay
or they're gonna go half the time they
already know
and every time I have tattle told it has
done nothing but caused me problems you
know for people that I'm not even that
good of friends with so if I see
cheating and
it's I'm not that close with the girl on
my team and this in this situation or
the guy or whatever it is I call me
crazy I just try to stay out of that
that is not my not my business and
you know people on the internet will go
find people if I say the actual name
from these stories and like go
and you know it's kind of like when
you're telling a story to 500 people you
don't think anyone's gonna do that
so you might use their their name
but it's not even just that even even so
much so that they'll they'll find my
sisters and they'll DM my sisters or my
mother or whoever it is and
part of the way I look at it is you know
if you choose to be on the internet
you know that's what comes with it but
it's hard the bigger you get because
people start to go for like your friends
your family they start they start to DM
people that you were friends with before
and then it's like
you know you know anyone with a picture
with you that knew you at any point in
your life can now has incentive to come
forward and just talk [ __ ] even if it's
made up even if that's some crazy [ __ ]
you took a picture with at a party four
years ago I swear to God they'll say
they were they were your best friends
and it's just like the [ __ ] that comes
with Fame is like
crazy and I don't even think of you know
like famous famous it's just more like
yeah so it's just stuff I didn't really
think about because I thought that I
would do well on YouTube but I didn't
think I'd do this well
I got 130 000 subscribers this month I
thought I'd be at like 100k Maybe 150k
by now I didn't think half a million
and I'm grateful shout out y'all shout
out y'all you're good you give me the
best job on the planet but
foreign
but my point is the bigger you get you
have to almost change your speech and
you have to think about what you say a
lot more because people will clip it
they'll take you out of context they'll
try to misinterpret you they will go
back and find something you said three
years ago and be like that contradicted
so I'm like yeah probably you know as
over time your thoughts change on things
um
sorry and that storage ran out and then
and then people will start to feel
entitled they'll be like oh
well
why don't you tell me every detail of
your dating life and I'm just like
I know I talk about dating and maybe you
guys feel like you're owed
a complete 180 of everything I do
um but I've just learned with the
internet if you give them an inch
they'll take a freaking mile
because then it's like
oh God it's like
they're like
oh um
I'm about every single detail and I'm
just like what the chill out guys you
gotta chill out anyways
so the next the next yeah so they say
you're I need to know your dating life
you're not attractive enough and then
every girl I disagree with they're like
oh you're just jealous because she's
prettier than you oh my gosh
I think I'm normal looking most girls
are probably
like if you're average half of them are
going to be prettier than you
um and then they'll say oh you
regurgitate manosphere talking points
you're a grifter and this is an
irritating thing I don't sell anything
I don't sell anything that's what annoys
me is when people call me a grifter what
what do I sell
I sell social media coaching
I'm like find me a course and you know
what I'm not going to name names I'm not
going to name names but some people that
call me that in this space sell
thousands of dollars worth of courses
and make and I don't knock you for it go
make that coin go make that bread I will
never but how are you gonna call me a
grifter when you are
fun selling thousands of dollars in
courses stop it stop it stop it right
now
um anyways do you regurgitate talking
points and you know what's irritating I
I quote people all the time or I say I
may not every it's it's tough you know
when you when you talk about ideas you
can't say oh by the way Jordan Peterson
came up with that every single time like
we're talking about the pay Gap like
Jordan Peterson articulated that in his
this interview two years ago or Rolo
tomasi or Thomas Sowell or whoever it
was guys I I will say right here and
right now
I did not come up with all the ideas I
say I did it
um
uh people smarter than me I really like
reading books I really like listening to
podcasts and if someone knows something
I will I will I will Google it to make
sure it's right and if it's right
then then I'll repeat it sorry but you
could you could say that's a bad thing I
don't because that's the thing if it's
true who cares where I got it from
that's that's what I don't get like a
lot of times when we're arguing about
truth it's like then they'll be like
well tell me about your dating life and
I'm like no no is this true or is it not
true and I'll be like wow Rolo tomasi
said that is it true or is it not true
and
yeah this is interesting
um
the other thing that's interesting about
content creation is there's like these
clicks and it's kind of like
people won't work with each other
based on like click it's very odd but
that's that's a whole nother
that's a it's just interesting because
I think of this in business and I wonder
if it's the same thing in business and
you guys can let me know there's a lot
of business people that follow me
if if two business people don't like
each other and there's business person C
do the does business person c not work
with one person because the other I
don't know it's interesting I don't
really care I try to stay out of all
that stuff but it's just an interesting
world that I've stumbled across but
anyways
um
[Music]
you know
see then but see this is how I think I'm
like oh God are people gonna take that
out of context I don't know anyways
anyways
let me know what y'all think in the
description I've covered a lot of points
today uh like the video on your way out
subscribe to the channel and I'll talk
to you next time